[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
your friendly neighborhood spoiler man
and with season two of the boys wrapping
up
i thought i'd go through the entire
thing again and give you 52 of my
favorite details and easter eggs from
the series
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the season yet then i highly
recommend that you check out now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
breakdown
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our list
okay so our first easter egg comes in
episode one
right at the beginning when we see the
statue of the seven being corrected
now include starlight instead of
lamplighter it really burns me up inside
and outside for that matter but the
creative team confirmed that this was
actually a reference to the statue at
the end of avengers age of ultron
which appears in the credits scene of
that movie it's not long
until we're at translucent's funeral and
we can see a completely clear casket for
the character
there's a lot of irony to the
proceedings as the corporation
are not being transparent about what
really happened to him and instead they
blame his death on the cartel super
terrorists
named el diablo they're using his death
as a platform to announce their war on
terror
which they will use to push compound b
the song starlight sings is also
available on vortify
showing that the corporation have their
hands in absolutely everything
they're almost like some multinational
corporation
that also make a streaming service of
songs and
will soon be running the world we also
learn about citizen starlight
which is a show that we'll be releasing
on board plus a play on disney plus
not long after we cut to huey and annie
in their respective hideouts
and we can hear the song pressure in the
background by billy joel
joel has numerous songs that appear
throughout the season including only the
good die young
we didn't start the fire and a lot more
in episode 8 we learned that huey loves
him so much
because it reminds him of his mother who
used to play the artist when he was a
kid
however if you cast your mind back to
season 1 you may remember that just
before robin was hit by a train
the pair were also talking about billy
joel i kind of think that joel
reminds him of the good times before his
life went to hell
and this is why he constantly plays his
music on the flip side of this
mother's milk often wears hip-hop group
t-shirts throughout the series
and though we don't learn why this is
throughout he only really wears groups
instead of solo artists
huey initially only wears solo artists
but towards the end of the series he
starts to wear groups
such as journey and fleetwood mac this
could showcase that he has stopped
working as an individual
and decided to become part of the bigger
hole so
give that give the ladder hug he
deserves it now on top of this billy
joel has an album called stormfront
which here nice little time together
there with the big villain of the series
starlight and huey meet on a train and
we can see someone reading a newspaper
with billy butcher on the front
on the back in the sports section is a
picture of shockwave
and it states that he's set a new speed
record shockwave actually ends up
replacing a train in the seven
and this is a nice little bit of
foreshadowing that's set up really well
here
we also see a poster for the church of
the collective just behind huey as he's
standing up on the train
and this group of course become very
important to the deep
now speaking of the deep when he's
having a meltdown at a water park
he mentions swimming in the mariana
trench in the aquaman movie this was a
massive scene
and with him being so close to the
character i think that it was
intentionally put here
now after reyna's head explodes the boys
panic and drive away from the scene
which is where they say who do you know
who can do that and frenchie replies
no one this is when we cut to victorian
newman on tv
which gives a little subliminal hint
that she's actually the one who carried
it out
shouts to screen crush for spotting that
one very good work
now in the office edgar mentions soulja
boy who we see a statue of in episode 7
just before stormfront and homelanders
rally soldier boy is going to be played
by jensen ackles
and he will appear in the upcoming
season as one of its main villains
the episode also features annie sitting
on a bench and throughout the series
benches have been an important place for
her and this is actually where she met
hughie in both the first season and
comic
the season also ends with the two
meeting up at one so it's nice to have
this motif constantly popping up
throughout the series
jump over to episode 2 and we see the
girls get it done slogan
for the very first time this of course
appears in the seven movie
and also in the finale when the girls
kick the crap out of stormfront
also has a lightning symbol for her
earrings and this was used not only by
the ss
but also as a symbol of fascism in
general this of course gives us a clue
that she has a secret agenda
and in addition to this stormfront.org
is actually a neo-nazi website
whose original domain was liberty.net
huge shout out to the creative team for
lacing the show with such deep easter
eggs
and the deep also has his girls saying
you are so beautiful to me
and this was done by pan oswald who who
is a big fan
of the comics look maybe the maybe the
easter eggs
aren't all that good yeah but we're
trying now at rainer's funeral we see
that instead of flowers
billy has has brought some lovely lovely
fruit
and this is a call back to season one in
which reiner brought up the time that
billy sent us some edible arrangements
as a gift
nice now homelander visits ryan and when
he's in bed the character gives him a v
phone which is of course a play on the
iphone further showing that bought or an
evil corporation
that want to take over the world cut to
a terrorist looking at a picture of the
brooklyn bridge
and this is another nod to the comics as
in that the seven crashed a plane into
it on 911.
the plane seen in the series rift on
this quite a bit but in the comics it
went above and beyond that
with having the seven basically caused
one of the biggest disasters in human
history
in episode three we see the director of
the seven movie dawn of the seven
going through the storyboards dawn of
the seven is of course a play on batman
v superman dawn of justice
and the movie itself is sort of
satirizing both the avengers and justice
league
as mentioned earlier this film pops up
throughout the season
and i love at one point how there's a
mention of a joss rewrite
joss whedon was brought on to replace
zack snyder on the justice league movie
and well if you've been you've been
following our channel then you
must know you must know how we feel
about it
now han zimmer is also mentioned in the
scene and he was of course the composer
that worked on man of steel and bbs
in episode 4 we see his doppelganger
impersonates madeleine stilwell
which is a call back to when the
character did it in season 1.
doppelganger gives homeland a breast
milk at one point and this episode is
called nothing like it in the world
which is also the name of the issue that
centers around mother's milk origin
story
which we sort of hear about in this
entry in the comic counterpart we
learned that mother's milk had to pretty
much drink his mother's breast milk to
survive
and i love the way that they've kind of
tied it all together for this episode
[Music]
you
[Music]
homelander and doppelganger watch taxi
driver on tv
which culminates in a man going on a
murderous rampage inside an apartment
block
at the end of the movie he's labeled as
a hero even though
as an audience we know that he's a
complete maniac now i think that this is
actually a nod to stormfront
who in the prior entry too destroyed an
apartment block
and was labelled a hero after it the
film also has the main character coming
face to face with himself
which homelander does at the end of the
episode when doppelganger impersonates
him
we went over this whole thing in more
detail as well as the similarities in
our episode 4 breakdown
so definitely check it out after this if
you're enjoying the list
in that video we also discussed how
annie revealed that she has a knot in
her stomach whenever she walks around
boar tower
because she worries that homelander
could kill her at any moment
in the elevator this is realized as
homelander almost twists her stomach
open
and we see as her fears become realized
at the vending machine
annie also says that her favorite
chocolate did you say chocolate
chocolate your favorite chocolate bar is
almond joy
and later this is used to defeat black
noir due to his nut allergy
with or without nuts i loved how annie's
favorite chocolate bar was probably
his least favorite probably everyone's
least favorite
and the show kind of takes a dump on it
throughout most of the season
there's also a moment where black noir
talks to a vortech to try and locate
billy
and she offers him an arm and joy and he
just holds up a bin
which she then has to drop the bar into
never had one before but
i'm not rushing out to get one let's be
honest now when annie
hughie and mother's milk are on their
road trip they spot a homeland a
painting where he has a confederate flag
for a cape
we later learn that liberty operated in
this area and carried out several
racially based attacks
so it could be possible that she fuelled
racial tension in the area
now in episode 5 homelander shows up at
a protest
and we see that victoria newman is
leading it this is massively unexpected
and victoria doesn't take her eyes off
him just
in case she needs to take him out in the
crowd we also see a sign for vault lied
people died
which is a play on the slogan bush slide
and people died
this is recently been adapted to discuss
trump's handling of kovid
and his name instead of bush has trended
on twitter a couple of times this year
we catch ashley watching this and some
of her hair starts to fall out
and this is a call back to the comics in
which the same thing happens to a vote
assistant
who's stressed out about her job the
stormfront also talks about the church
of the collective to a train
and we see the name storefront on her
cup i can't even begin to explain the
amount of times i've been writing a
script
and i've typed that in by mistake so i'm
guessing that it happened when writing
the show too
we also see the deep's wedding which we
learned was set up by the church of the
collective
the deep is pretty much riffing on tom
cruise who's very much seen
as the face of the religion there's been
a long
unsubstantiated rumor that cruz is gay
and that his marriages were shams
which this seems to be playing upon the
church of the collective appeared
throughout the season at multiple points
and their book destinations has a cover
on it which is clearly pulling on the
novel dianetics by alron hubbard
they also drink fresca and this is an
ongoing joke with the creative team
who say that it's a very awful soft
drink again
not had it so can't comment we see brave
may being pitched
and the marketing team behind this are
called seth evan which is a nod to seth
rogen and evan goldberg
who are behind the show we're also
introduced to lamplighter played by sean
ashmore
and this is sort of a play on his role
in the x-men in which he played iceman
this character is iceman's opposite more
similar to pyro
and it's a nice little mirroring of the
past we also learn
in this episode from mallory that
frenchie killed a hero called cult snap
who was pretty much the boy's version of
iceman in episode 6 we go to the sage
grove center
and we see the character love sausage
who featured in the comics as an ally
for the boys
and was known for his his love sausage
lamplighter gets a lot of screen time
this episode and we see that his staff
is very similar to the green lantern's
power battery
which is a nod to the comics in general
uh yeah and
and how we look he looks really looks
terrible
in episode seven we see lamplighter and
huey watching
uh some movies and one of these has jack
from jupiter in it
this is a character from the comics
that's riffing on martian manhunter
and he was originally part of the seven
though we don't know what happened to
him here
homelander also appears to be banging
someone's wife
whilst they watch on and this is of
course a play on how he did the same
thing with becca
whilst billy had to deal with the
repercussions of it at the end of the
episode
we see a lot of heads popping off and
this is actually a reference of the
comics
in which several supes were given
modified versions of compound b
that if triggered correctly would cause
their heads to explode
billy actually carried this out and it
was an amazing moment
early on in the run in episode 8 we
catch ryan going through all the states
in the us
and this could be a nod to soldier boy
in the comics who also does the same
thing
it is possible that he will actually end
up taking the mantle
as in the original work we did discover
that there were three versions of the
character
early on in the episode we catch the
boys preparing to fight the supes
and amongst some of the chemicals we can
also see a snickers bar
which i'm guessing would be used on
black noir there's also a news report
that says stormfront has been connected
to jeffrey epstein's death
and i don't believe the bloody fake news
when becca dies it's at the hands of
ryan
aka homelanders child and in the comics
her fate is
sort of the same way however it's far
more extreme
in that the fetus inside her powers
itself out of her stomach
and can be seen floating above her dead
body yikes
the episode ends with homelander and
beating himself up
on the edge of the chrysler building and
this scene was originally filmed for the
first season
but it was cut for being far too vulgar
in the comics a similar scene happens
with the soup staring out over the city
saying that he can do anything and this
is where he really goes off the deep end
and therefore i can't wait to see what
happens with him next time
anyway that's the list and obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on this
season
and if there's any easter eggs that you
think should have made it i know a lot
of these have probably been pointed out
either by myself or by the channels but
i thought i just put together a list of
my 52
favorites so you can see how nuanced the
show really is
if you enjoy this video and want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our season 3 theories
video which is going to be linked at the
end
we discuss all the big ones so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat with us on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you